foreign
how should people think about defining
philosophy of History
that's number one
and number two
is
the Taylor line related to historical
sensibility being similar to musical
Sensibility
and if you could just say more about
that
the philosophy of history is barely
studied
or indeed taught and yet you can't
really be an historian without a
philosophy of History you have to
understand the nature of causation these
days nobody bothers with that which is
why a lot of academic history is garbage
I became fascinated by the philosophy of
History
at that time when I was drinking chateau
lefeed with Jack Plum and realized that
there was a very Central problem namely
that any causal statement this is
obvious to philosophers and it's obvious
to people who do the law implies are
counterfactual in other words if we say
that the conversation between Tim
Ferriss and Neil Ferguson in November
2022 led to the outbreak of War
between China and the United States the
following year that implies that if we
hadn't had the conversation the war
wouldn't have happened and so the what
if question what if they hadn't had the
conversation is a legitimate question in
the same way if you think that Hitler
was the key architect of World War II
and it wouldn't have happened without
him then it's legitimate to ask what
would have happened if Hitler had in
fact been assassinated prior to
September 1939. so those what-if
questions were of great importance to me
as a young scholar and teacher that was
how I used to teach students I would say
well what if what if that hadn't
happened what if Britain hadn't
intervened in 1914
Taylor was a historian who was
sympathetic to that approach
his view was a somewhat
skeptical ironical view that men only
learn from history how to make new
mistakes and his books are shot through
with the the role of contingency
one of the things that made Taylor
attractive to me in parentheses Was His
Brilliant prose style up there with
George Orwell as one of the master
stylists of the 20th century and a
tremendous master of paradox
enough one-liners to the line about the
1848 revolutions as being the the
turning point when Germany failed to
turn all that stuff I found exciting
because
being able to write like that is also
the way to convince a reader to be able
to talk like that is to convince an
audience so that's how the philosophy of
History relates to the style of of
History
the second question
that you asked about music his his
assertion that that the historical
sensibility is a bit like the uh
receptiveness to music is is Right
history is not a science it can't be a
science because we can't re-run events
and laboratory and see if consistently
War breaks out in 1939 with or without
Hitler
so what we're doing when we study the
past as a great Oxford philosopher of
History R.G Collingwood said is we're
kind of reconstituting past Human
Experience from the bits and pieces that
have been left behind and as we do that
it's a very subtle process of of mental
reenactment of experience and I'm not
sure that Taylor was wrong to compare it
to that that musical side of of the
human psyche interestingly someone else
said much the same thing a man named
Fritz Kramer who was Henry Kissinger's
great mentor during and after World War
II and Kramer said that that Kissinger
had this kind of sensibility uh he was
attuned to history I I think that's a
very very right
you've got to have
the ear for it and it's quite obvious
when one reads a book when a historian's
tone deaf and shouldn't really have gone
into the business just as it would be
obvious if they tried to conduct an
orchestra or play a concerto so yeah I
think it's much closer to music than it
is to science